Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. had the greeks been defeated at salamis not only would the west lost its first struggle for independence and survival but it is unlikely that there would have ever been such an entity as the west at all so says the blurb for a little known history book called persian fire by tom holland did i really write that good grief you did write that you did write that so we ended the last um episode of the rest is history on a moment of extraordinary tension anticipation and drama the great persian army of xerxes has crossed the hellespont and the fleet they've crossed the Hellespont they've come all the way down into central Greece Athens is at bay um the Spartans have pitched up at the hot gates
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要每周收听独家加更节目、无广告内容、系列节目抢先体验，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。如果希腊人在萨拉米斯战役中战败，西方不仅会失去其对独立和生存的首次抗争，而且西方作为一个实体可能根本就不会存在——这是汤姆·霍兰所著的一本鲜为人知的历史书《波斯之火》的封底简介。我真的写过那种话吗？天哪，你确实写过，你确实写过。所以上一集的《The Rest Is History》在一种极度紧张、期待和戏剧化的氛围中结束。薛西斯庞大的波斯军队已经穿过了赫勒斯庞特海峡，他们的舰队穿过了赫勒斯庞特海峡，一路南下进入希腊中部，雅典陷入绝境，斯巴达人在温泉关驻扎了下来。
of Thermopylae hoping to block the Persian advance and we ended last time with you saying there was electricity in the air quite literally so I'm looking forward to finding out what happens next okay so the the the fleet at artemisian the watchtower on skathos has signaled that the persian fleet is coming and um there's a squadron of of sidonian ships that's from sidon in phoenician the phoenicians are the kind of the great naval power of the mediterranean the great rivals to the greeks and they are subject to to the Persian king there are three there are three Greek ships um they don't put up a great show one of them gets captured another one runs onto a shoal and the third one comes back and says ah the Persians are coming that's no good no it's not it's not a good start but then but then they wait for the
他们希望借此阻挡波斯的推进。我们在上一集结束时，你说空气中弥漫着紧张的气氛，可以说是字面意义上的“火药味”。所以我很期待接下来会发生什么。好吧，斯基亚索斯的瞭望塔发出信号，通报阿尔忒密西翁的舰队，说波斯舰队正在靠近。有一支西顿战舰中队来自腓尼基的西顿。腓尼基人可以说是地中海伟大海军强国，也是希腊人的死敌，他们臣服于波斯国王。当时有三艘希腊船只，它们的表现算不上出色，其中一艘被俘，另一艘搁浅，第三艘折返并报告说：“啊，波斯人来了，这下不妙了。”没错，这绝对算不上一个好的开端。但随后，他们开始等待波斯舰队的到来。
persian fleet to arrive and the persian fleet doesn't arrive and they the the greeks begin to realize that this was just a kind of you know uh advance guard sent to scope things out meanwhile at thermopylae this huge dust cloud the earth is starting to shake and the Spartans begin to realise that, you know, the king is coming. The Persian settle on the great plain that kind of extends beyond the gates, the hot gates. And a cavalryman rides up to scope out the hot gates. And there they find that theartans are combing their hair combing their hair wrestling yeah combing they have they wear their hair very long right um and it's slightly bemused by that slightly bemused by this um uh xerxes has a
然而波斯舰队并没有出现，希腊人开始意识到这只是一种为了侦察情况而派出的先头部队。与此同时，在温泉关，尘土飞扬，大地开始颤动，斯巴达人开始意识到国王要来了。波斯人扎营在延伸至温泉关外的广阔平原上。一名骑兵骑马前来侦察温泉关。在那里，他们发现斯巴达人正在梳理头发，摔跤，是的，他们梳着头发。他们的头发留得很长，对吧？波斯人对此感到有些困惑，对此感到有些困惑。薛西斯手下有一位斯巴达国王
spartan king demaratus who's been a great rival of Cleomenes who's gone into exile he's basically been deposed and he's so cross at this that he he goes off to side with the Persians and Demaratus explains that it is the custom of the Spartans to comb their hair in preparation for battle so they they're getting ready for the big fight um Xerxes sends an ambassador to demand that the the Spartans hand over their their weapons uh Lenida says come and get them kind of classic example of the uh the spartans hand over their their weapons uh lenny just says come and get them kind of classic example of the uh the spartans clint eastwood-esque i was about to say iconic sense of humor come and get them come and get them punk um so all is set ready for ready for the battle uh but then i said that electricity is in the air and so it is and you'll remember perhaps
名为德玛拉图斯，他曾是克里昂米尼的死敌，后来流亡海外，基本上被废黜了。他对此极为恼火，于是转投波斯一方。德玛拉图斯解释说，斯巴达人有在战前梳理头发的习惯，所以他们正在为大战做准备。薛西斯派了一名使者，要求斯巴达人交出武器。列奥尼达说：“来拿吧。”这绝对是斯巴达人标志性幽默的经典例子。克林特·伊斯特伍德式的……我正要说那种标志性的幽默感。“来拿吧，来拿吧，小伙子。”万事俱备，只欠东风，大战一触即发。正如我刚才所说，空气中弥漫着紧张的气氛，确实如此。你可能还记得第一集的内容，
from part one that um xerxes had uh had the helispont branded and fettered and this has clearly annoyed poseidon because a terrible storm starts to brew and for two days it rages howls and screams and the persians are kind of huddled in front of the hot gate so they don't move greek fleet is beached up on on artemisian they don't go to sea but the persian fleet is caught in the the eye of the storm and the greeks hope you know that the entire fleet might have been wrecked in due course after the storm starts to fade they discover that this hasn't actually happened but a sizable proportion of the Persian fleet has indeed been destroyed the Persian fleet still you know heavily heavily outnumbers the Greek fleet perhaps by three three to one, perhaps. But the odds have been reduced.
薛西斯曾让人用烙铁烙印并用枷锁锁住赫勒斯庞特海峡，这显然激怒了波斯人的海神波塞冬，一场可怕的风暴开始酝酿，狂风呼啸，持续了两天。波斯人缩在温泉关前不敢动弹。希腊舰队停泊在阿尔忒密西翁，没有出海，而波斯舰队却不幸遭遇了风暴眼。希腊人希望整个舰队能在风暴中悉数沉没。随着风暴逐渐平息，他们发现并没有发生这种情况，但波斯舰队相当大的一部分确实被摧毁了。不过，波斯舰队的数量依然远超希腊舰队，大约可能是三比一的比例。尽管如此，双方的悬殊差距还是缩减了。
Yeah. And so we're set up for these twin battles, the Battle of Artemisian and the Battle of Thermopylae. And the state is that the Spartans have to hold the hot gates, the Athenians and the rest of the Greek fleet have to kind of hold the Artemisian. Because that's the only way that that that the persians can be stopped so if one if one is forced if the sea or the land route is is is forced then the then it's all forced and they all have to retreat what's they holding the persian the hot gates for to
是的。因此，接下来我们将迎来两场决战：阿尔忒密西翁海战和温泉关之战。目前的形势是，斯巴达人必须守住温泉关，而雅典人及其他希腊舰队则必须守住阿尔忒密西翁。因为这是阻止波斯的唯一途径。所以，如果其中一方失守，无论是海上还是陆路通道被攻破，那么防线就会全面崩溃，他们都将不得不撤退。他们死守温泉关是为了什么？
to buy time to what's the reason yeah so so essentially they're waiting for reinforcements to come up so if you remember the Spartans are not coming because because um the Olympic festival is being celebrated they're watching the Olympics and the other thing is is that they know that um you know the logistics of this is is tough for the Persians because if they can hold them say for a for a week for two weeks for three weeks then the Persian army will start to starve and if the Persian army starts to starve then that reflects badly on xerxes whose entire authority is dependent upon the assumption that you know he can command um yeah you know earth and water so two questions so two questions
为了争取时间，原因是什么？是的，所以他们基本上是在等待增援部队的到来。如果你还记得的话，斯巴达人之所以没有及时赶到，是因为当时正在举行奥林匹克运动会，他们正在观赛。另一个原因是，他们知道波斯的后勤补给对他们来说非常艰难。所以，如果他们能坚守一周、两周或三周，波斯军队就会开始挨饿。而一旦波斯军队挨饿，这对薛西斯来说就会产生非常负面的影响，因为他的绝对权威完全建立在“他能够掌控大地与水”这一假设之上。所以有两个问题。
one how many persians are there i would say that the the total of the four of the land forces commanded by xerxes would be about 250 to 300 000 i mean that's that's an estimate that's we don't know because the second question yeah related to the first question how are they being supplied are they living off the land have the greeks have the greeks done a scorched earth thing or not no they haven't done that and and so the fact that they're living off the land puts pressure on the local greeks and this is important because there is actually a pass around the back there is a path that goes round the uh round the hot gates um and lenny just knows about this because he's been told about this by locals and so he has sent um a band of local hoplites to guard it but he can't spare
第一个问题：波斯人到底有多少？我认为薛西斯麾下的陆军总兵力大约在25万到30万之间。我的意思是，这只是一个估计，我们并不确切知道。第二个问题，与第一个问题相关：他们是如何获得补给的？他们是靠就地征粮吗？希腊人有没有采取焦土政策？不，他们没有那样做。因此，他们依靠当地物资维持生活，这给当地的希腊人带来了压力。这一点很重要，因为实际上后方有一条小路，有一条绕过温泉关的小路。列奥尼达知道这一点，因为当地人把这个秘密告诉了他。因此，他派了一队当地的重装步兵去把守，但他抽不出
anyone else to do it so he's just taking a pump that the person that the persians are not going to find out about this the problem is that the persians are very good at finding out things like that both because you know they're very very good at intelligence and that they're a mountain people and they're incredibly proficient at forcing passes so basically the battle of thermopylae is a disaster for the greeks lenny does is an incredibly incompetent general um that's not uh because you often hear essentially gerard butler essentially what happens is that the spartans and the other greeks are able to hold the pass for two days and that that is an amazing feat. Against the sheer weight of numbers that Xerxes can command,
其他人去支援了，所以他只能赌一把，希望波斯人不会发现这条小路。问题是，波斯人非常擅长打听这类消息，一方面是因为他们非常擅长搜集情报，另一方面他们是山地民族，极其擅长强行穿过关隘。所以，基本上温泉关之战对希腊人来说是一场灾难。列奥尼达是一个极其无能的将军，这并不是……因为你经常听到……基本上就是杰拉德·巴特勒演的那样。实际情况是，斯巴达人和其他希腊人成功坚守了关隘两天，这已经是一个了不起的壮举了。面对薛西斯能够调动的绝对数量优势，
that is an incredibly heroic thing to have done. But Leonidas is comprehensively outsmarted by Xerxes' intelligence agency because a local Greek, a guy called Ephialtes, essentially blows the secret. And whether he does this for financial gain whether he does it because he's you know pissed off that you know his farm is being kind of sacked by the persians or whatever yeah he reveals the fact that there is this path up around the back and xerxes sends his crack squad which is is called the Immortals, because every time it's that there are a thousand of them that have golden apples on the butt of their spears.
这已经是一件极其英勇的事了。但列奥尼达被薛西斯的谍报机构彻底智取了，因为一个名叫埃菲阿尔特斯的当地希腊人基本上泄露了秘密。不管他是为了金钱利益，还是因为对自己的农场被波斯人劫掠感到愤怒，或者是出于其他什么原因，总之他透露了后方有这样一条小路。于是薛西斯派出了他的王牌精锐部队——号称“长生军”的部队，因为他们每支长矛的末端都有金苹果装饰，且每队正好有一千人。
There are 9000 that have silver apples. And every time one of them falls, he's immediately replaced. So hence, they're called Immortals. They wear these kind of beautiful robes. They are the best troops at Xerxes' command. They are kind of the equal of the Spartans. And he sends them up around the back and the news is brought to Leonidas because the hoplite forces have been put there rather than trying to block the path retreats up the side of a mountain and the immortals are not
还有九千人的长矛末端装饰着银苹果。每当其中一人倒下，就会立刻有人替补上。因此，他们被称为“长生军”。他们穿着精美的长袍，是薛西斯麾下最精锐的部队，实力堪与斯巴达人匹敌。薛西斯派他们从后方绕过去。消息传到了列奥尼达耳中，因为那些原本被派去驻守小路而不是试图封锁它的重装步兵撤到了山腰上，而“长生军”对他们
interested in them they're interested in forcing the path so they just keep heading down so Leonidas knows that um that that everything is doomed his task now is to ensure that as many of the 5,000 troops that are with him can get away and so he decides that he is going to stay and try and um keep the Persians engaged so that the the others that are retreating can get away and he is the 300 him and 300 that's the 300 also um the thespians from which is a city very nearby a great enemy of the thebans but also the look the theban um the thebans who want to uh you know they don't want to go back to their their their own city because they know now that thieves is going to go over to persia so these these guys hope that they decide to stay um lady just has this kind of you know eat well for breakfast because tonight we dine in hades again kind of classic clint eastwood
并不感兴趣，他们的目标是强行突破关隘，所以他们继续向前推进。因此列奥尼达知道一切都已注定，他现在的任务是确保与他同行的那五千名士兵中尽可能多的人能够撤离。于是他决定留下来，试图牵制波斯人，好让正在撤退的其他人能够脱身。他留下了这300人，加上他自己总共300人，这就是“斯巴达三百勇士”。此外，还有来自附近一座城市的忒斯比人，他们是底比斯人的死敌，但同时也有底比斯人……那些底比斯人不想回到自己的城市，因为他们知道底比斯即将投降波斯。所以这些人决定留下来。列奥尼达说了这样一句话：“大家早餐吃饱点，因为今晚我们将在冥界共进晚餐。”这又是一个典型的克林特·伊斯特伍德式
staff um and xerxes obviously dines much better you. He breakfasts much more palatably. And then he sends the troops into the hot gates. And this time, the Spartans and the other hoplites, they'd previously built this kind of wall and they'd fought for behind this wall. This time they go out into the open. says that um the the the the xerxes troops are so intimidated by the um by the sight of the spartans you know these spears bristling the red cloaks the red horse hair um kind of terrifying sight that they have to be forced by whips to approach the Spartans. And it's often thought that this is kind of Greek propaganda. But it seems to me entirely plausible because Xerxes doesn't want to waste his best troops. And he has all this kind of cannon fodder.
的台词。薛西斯显然吃得比他们好得多，他的早餐要美味得多。然后他命令部队发起进攻。这一次，斯巴达人和其他重装步兵不再固守他们之前修建并借此战斗的防御墙，而是直接出击，来到开阔地带。历史记载称，薛西斯的士兵被斯巴达人的阵势——密密麻麻的长矛、红色的斗篷、红色的马鬃装饰——吓得胆战心惊，那是一种极其恐怖的景象，以至于他们必须在皮鞭的抽打下才敢靠近斯巴达人。人们常认为这可能是希腊人的政治宣传，但在我看来这完全合乎情理，因为薛西斯并不想浪费他最精锐的部队，而他手头有的是这种炮灰。
And sure, the Greeks will kill them. But it doesn't really matter because they're entirely expendable. And in due course course their spears will be splintered so it seems it does seem to me credible and you may wonder well how does Herodotus know this bearing in mind that all the Greeks die well there's Demaratus the Spartan who is you know ex-king who is there and who does seem to have been consulted by Herodotus because he gets quite a lot of his information from Demaratus so it does seem to me at least plausible that this happened and that in due course, the Spartans lose their spears,
当然，希腊人会杀死他们，但这根本无关紧要，因为他们完全是可以牺牲的。随着时间的推移，他们的长矛会被折断，所以这在我看来是可信的。你可能会好奇，既然希腊人全军覆没，希罗多德又是怎么知道这些细节的呢？别忘了，当时有斯巴达人德玛拉图斯，他是一位流亡的前国王，当时就在现场，而且希罗多德显然向他咨询过，因为他获取的大量信息都来自于德玛拉图斯。所以在我看来，这件事至少是合情合理的：随着时间的推移，斯巴达人的长矛折断了，
they're fighting with their swords and then they retreat to this kind of this hill. The Thebans, they split off, they get captured, then surrender. But the Spartans and the Sethsapians fight on. Laenidas falls in the battle. His corpse is fought over herodotus says as you know the body of patroclus was fought over by the greeks and or by the greeks and the trojans um lenny just uh perishes all the spartans perish everybody gets wiped out and this is the
他们开始用短剑战斗，随后退守到了一座小山丘上。底比斯人则选择脱离队伍，先是被俘，随后投降。但斯巴达人和忒斯比人仍在继续战斗。列奥尼达在战斗中阵亡。希罗多德记载，双方为争夺他的尸体展开了激烈的争夺，正如当年希腊人和特洛伊人争夺帕特洛克罗斯的尸体一样。列奥尼达战死，所有的斯巴达人阵亡，无人生还。这就是
famous last stand of the spartans and in due course, when all is silent, at last Xerxes rides into the pass. You know, it's a kind of mulch of gore and intestines and twisted limbs. Leonidas' body is found, his decapitated head put on a spike. Meanwhile, the news has been brought to the Greek fleet who've been putting up a very very good show
斯巴达人著名的悲壮坚守。最终，当一切归于寂静，薛西斯终于骑马进入了关隘。那是一片混杂着血肉、内脏和扭曲肢体的泥泞之地。人们找到了列奥尼达的尸体，他的头颅被砍下并挂在了长矛上。与此同时，消息传到了希腊舰队那里。尽管寡不敌众，但他们在与波斯的战斗中表现得非常出色。
against the Persians even though they're very outnumbered what they have realized is that if they can fight in close quarters they are able to you know to beat the Persians basically if they can get them in close quarters then there is a chance but they know now that there is no prospect you know there's no point in staying where they are they've got to retreat the road to Athens is now open so they withdraw in the night because they know that the night before uh the last stand at Thermopylae so they know that they're doomed so they get away and the troops that Lenidas has sent they also get away. But it's a disastrous situation because the road to Athens is now open. Athens is doomed. And a Spartan king has been killed. So you may well wonder, where does this myth of Thermopylae as a kind of victory, as a defeat that's kind of more glorious
他们意识到，如果能进行近身肉搏，他们就有机会击败波斯人。基本上，只要能把波斯人拖入近战，他们就有一线生机。但现在他们知道，继续留在这里已经没有任何意义和前景了，他们必须撤退。通往雅典的道路已经敞开，于是他们在夜里撤退了——那是温泉关最后坚守的前一夜。他们知道自己大限已至，所以选择了撤离。列奥尼达派出的军队也成功撤离了。但局势依然是一场灾难，因为通往雅典的大门已经敞开，雅典在劫难逃，而且一位斯巴达国王也阵亡了。所以你可能会想，温泉关之战作为一个悲壮的转折点——一场比胜利还要光彩夺目的失败——这种神话究竟是从何而来的呢？
than a victory, where does it come from? and i think it probably doesn't come from sparta because the spartans aren't very good at that kind of stuff the guy who's brilliant at this kind of stuff is themistocles so i think it's it's an athenian myth i i think it's probably themistocles is kind of blowing that particular trumpet which is an irony because he's brilliant at this kind of stuff anyway themistocles comes back to athens and he discovers that the city is only half evacuated and he kind of says guys get a move on and so now the evacuation proceeds full full scope and all these kind of stories of uh you know ships crossing the sea dogs following them xanthippus who is uh he'd been sent into exile
我认为它大概不是源自斯巴达，因为斯巴达人并不擅长搞这种舆论宣传。真正擅长此道的高手是地米斯托克利。所以我认为这是一个雅典神话，大概是地米斯托克利在极力吹捧和操纵此事。说来具有讽刺意味的是，他本来就是玩弄这种手腕的天才。无论如何，地米斯托克利回到雅典后，发现这座城市只疏散了一半人，于是他催促大家：“伙计们，动作快点！”于是疏散工作全面展开。关于船只出海、狗在后面追赶的故事也随之流传开来——桑提波斯，他之前曾因陶片放逐法
um with the ostracism but all the people who've been sent into exile have been called back he's the father of pericles who will in due course be the great you know the great leader of athens he he sets he sets ship for for salamis and his dog follows him all the way he lands on the island of salad paddling yeah he lands there the dog reaches the beach totters up and expires oh that's it's kind of a story dogs keep dying in this podcast and it's the same when it happens now let me stop the narrative there tom let me let me get you to pipe down because we can do some questions okay before we move on to there so we had tons of questions about thermopylae specifically we may as well just go through them so preston k
而被流放，但所有被流放的人此时都被召回了。他是伯里克利的父亲，后者日后将成为雅典的伟大领袖。他登船前往萨拉米斯，而他的忠犬一路尾随。当他登上萨拉米斯岛时，小狗涉水上岸，
pearl says were there actually 300 spartans defending the gates or is this a sort of invented number no what's the answer absolutely there were 300 spartans we know that because 300 is is a significant number it's the number of the hippeas um which is the kind of the elite squad the people who've listened to the sparta episode may remember the equivalent of the duke of edinburgh award yes um you know you you get your gold award and then you could join the hippeis which is basically the bodyguards of the kings the elite republican guard to use an uh as a same analogy yes exactly an elite squad of crack-picked men to use the uh we have ways uh formulation the the the 300 that follow lenidas are not the kind of classic hippias because these are these
步履蹒跚地爬上海滩，然后倒地气绝身亡。哦，这……在这个播客里狗怎么一直在死，每次讲到这儿都是这样。好了，汤姆，我先打断一下叙事，让你先喘口气，因为我们接下来要回答几个问题。在继续之前，我们收到了海量关于温泉关的具体提问，我们不妨逐一解答。普雷斯顿·K·
are older men who have um they've had children yeah so but yes we know that they're 300 okay so next question matthew butcher uh often a long-time listener. I often see him on Twitter. He says, without the betrayal, i.e. without this business of the other path, could the Greeks have held the Persians at Thermopylae indefinitely? It sounds like the answer is no. Am I right? Well, had there not been a path round the pass, they could have done. But there's always a way around a pass that's that's
珀尔问：“当时真的只有300名斯巴达人在防守关隘吗？还是说这是一个虚构的数字？”答案是绝对的，确实有300名斯巴达人。我们之所以知道这一点，是因为300是一个具有特殊意义的数字，它是“希佩伊斯”（Hippeis）卫队的编制人数。听过斯巴达那一集的朋友可能还记得，这就相当于爱丁堡公爵奖章的地位。是的，你拿到了金奖，然后就可以加入“希佩伊斯”。它基本上是国王的近卫军，用现代的比喻来说，就是精锐的共和国卫队。没错，正是由精挑细选的精锐勇士组成的一支队伍。用我们另一档节目《We Have Ways》的习惯说法来形容，跟随列奥尼达的这300人并不完全是传统意义上的“希佩伊斯”，因为他们
the nature of passes um top geography here yeah but but the part the persians know this because they're very very expert both at fortifying and storming passes it's one of the things that they do never try to hold a pass against the person no so so there was no way that the spartans could ever have held it um they were always doomed but i mean you know if it was if the only way through was through the the hot gates then yes i i guess they they probably could have done well they probably get exhausted eventually i mean if yeah but but they've got reinforcements coming that's that's the point fair point fair point okay so sahanis has asked a question specifically about the persian army he or she says what proportion are fighting
年纪稍长，而且都已经有了孩子。但无论如何，我们确切知道确实有300人。好的，下一个问题来自马修·布彻，他是一位老听我在推特上发言的忠实听众。他问道：“如果没有叛徒，也就是如果没有那条小路的事，希腊人能在温泉关无限期地抵挡波斯人吗？听起来答案是否定的。我说的对吗？”嗯，如果没有那条绕过关隘的小路，他们确实能做到。但关隘总会有绕行的小路，
for the greater glory of persia is there any nationalist feeling are they basically mercenaries and and other mercenaries how much are they being paid they're levies so that's so most of the people are levies they're conscripts they this is part of the tribute that they have to pay the persians the persians themselves i mean it's a kind of great honor to fight for the king you know these are not armies like a modern army or indeed like the roman army who are kind of professionals these are you know these are levies uh or people who are you know for the persians the meads the absolute crack squad the the crack troops these are people who who are you know these are aristocrats aristocracies and every aristocrat has commands people who he's bringing with them and it's a
这就是地形的规律。这里涉及地理学。但是波斯人深谙此道，因为他们在筑垒攻坚和强行突破关隘方面都是顶尖专家。这也是他们的拿手好戏之一。永远不要试图跟波斯人死守关隘。所以，斯巴达人无论如何都不可能永远守住它，他们的结局早已注定。不过我的意思是，如果唯一的通道只有温泉关这一条，那他们确实大概能守住。当然，最终他们可能也会精疲力竭。如果……但问题是他们有增援部队在路上，这才是关键所在。有道理，有道理。好的，萨哈尼斯提出了一个专门针对波斯军队的问题。他/她问：“其中有多少比例是为了波斯的崇高荣耀而战？这里面有民族主义情感吗？他们基本上是雇佣兵吗？如果是雇佣兵，他们拿多少薪水？”他们是征召兵。所以，绝大多数人都是征召兵，是应征入伍的。这是他们必须向波斯缴纳的贡赋的一部分。至于波斯人自己，为国王作战是一种巨大的荣誉。这可不是现代军队那样的常备军，甚至也不像罗马军队那样职业化。这些人要么是征召兵，要么是……
great honor to to fight in the and what about the mercenaries tom because i'm thinking later on in history a couple of centuries later um when alexander the greatest fighting the persians the persons rely a lot on greek mercenaries is that the case now greek speaking mercenaries in xerxes's army uh no um because the reason that that persians subsequently use greek mercenaries is because it it dawns on them that greek heavy infantry are you know incomparable that no one can really beat them in a pitch battle so therefore they they do pave them. Xerxes doesn't need to pave them because the Ionians are his subjects. And because he's in person with hundreds of thousands of men behind him,
对于波斯人来说，米底人是绝对的核心精锐，他们是真正的王牌部队。这些人都是贵族。每个贵族都统率着他自己带来的部下，能够在军中效力是一种无上的崇高荣誉。那么雇佣兵呢，汤姆？因为我在想，在后来的历史中，几个世纪后，当亚历山大大帝与波斯人作战时，波斯人严重依赖希腊雇佣兵。现在也是这种情况吗？薛西斯的军队里有说希腊语的雇佣兵吗？没有。波斯人后来之所以使用希腊雇佣兵，是因为他们逐渐意识到希腊重装步兵是无可匹敌的，在阵地战中没有人能真正击败他们，所以他们才会花钱雇佣。但薛西斯当时并不需要花钱雇佣，因为爱奥尼亚人已经是他的臣民了。而且由于他亲自率领数十万大军亲征，
people who, Greek cities who are going over to him are very happy to do it in the assumption that they're going to be rewarded in due course so no there are no mercenaries and a question from me um about the technological difference between the armies so they're the same kind of military technological level or the greek hoplites kind of more advanced more heavily armed better spears or whatever what's the story well greek warfare is massively focused on heavy infantry so there's very little role for cavalry there's very little role for archery um the persians are very strong in both and they have heavy infantry as well it's just that what marathon had showed and it also thermopylae shows to a degree is that um if heavily armored greek
那些选择投靠他的希腊城邦都非常乐意效劳，因为他们认为自己在事后会得到丰厚的回报。所以，当时并没有雇佣兵。我还有一个关于两军技术差距的问题：他们的军事技术水平大致处于同一层次吗？还是说希腊重装步兵更先进、装备更重、长矛更精良之类的？具体情况是怎样的？希腊的军事体系高度聚焦于重装步兵，因此骑兵发挥的作用极小，弓箭手发挥的作用也非常小。相比之下，波斯人在骑兵和弓箭手方面都非常强大，而且他们也有重装步兵。只是马拉松战役以及在某种程度上温泉关战役所表明的是，
infantry can pin persian armies down they will probably win because not even the immortals can for instance can break the uh the spartan line at thermopylae because because they're too strong they're too heavily armored the shields the spears the helmets the armor is it just makes the greeks too very difficult to break them the the converse to that which is why the persians generally assume that they will beat the greeks is that they're immobile right so if you have cavalry if you have archers it's quite easy to beat them but you don't engage with them the terrain's not great for i suppose for sort of horse archers and stuff is it yeah so that's so that's the problem in greece yeah okay so last question on thermopylae specifically i think chet archbold who is a friend of the show says is
如果装备精良的希腊重装步兵能够将波斯军队死死缠住，他们通常就能获胜。因为哪怕是“长生军”，也无法在温泉关正面突破斯巴达人的防线。因为希腊人太强了，他们的装甲太厚重了——盾牌、长矛、头盔和铠甲，让希腊人的防线极其坚固，几乎无法被打破。与此相对的一面——这也是为什么波斯人通常认为自己一定能战胜希腊人的原因——在于希腊军队机动性较差。所以，如果你拥有骑兵和弓箭手，击败他们其实并不难，只要避免与他们近身肉搏就行。不过雅典周边的地形对于骑兵弓箭手之类兵种的施展来说，应该算不上太理想吧？是的，这正是当时在希腊作战的难题所在。好的，关于温泉关的最后一个问题，我想提问的是查特·阿尔奇博尔德，他是本节课的老朋友。他问道：
thermopylae the first instance of the narrative of the noble defeat? Is it all just cynical spin, or is there something more, perhaps even mythical to Thermopylae, like the Alamo or Dunkirk or something? So this goes to that point you made about, you think Themistocles is a key figure in kind of creating this myth. And a question I would add to Chet's question, is that sort of Dunkirk um sort of mythology is
温泉关之战是“高贵的失败”这一叙事的首例吗？这完全只是一场玩世不恭的政治公关，还是说温泉关之战背后有着更深层的含义，甚至带有一点神话色彩，就像阿拉莫战役、敦刻尔克撤退那样？这就回到了你之前提到的观点——你认为地米斯托克利是塑造这一神话的关键人物。我想顺着查特的问题再追加一个问题：这种类似于敦刻尔克的悲壮神话，
that created at the time or is it long after the event i don't think dunkirk is quite the analogy because at dunkirk they don't stand and fight so it's more rock drift or something isn't it i suppose yeah it except rock drift they survive um okay yeah it's it's it's the the kind of the it's the noble death it's general gordon we should definitely do a podcast general gordon well it's but more specifically it's it's i mean it's kind of rooted in the desire of achilles the great hero of the iliad who is given the choice of a long life and no glory or glory and a short life and that idea that you can have a noble death you know good death is a very important kind of part of the Greek psyche because that you know it's saturated with kind of Homeric ideas and I think that that's
究竟是在当时就被刻意塑造出来的，还是在事件发生很久之后才出现的？我觉得敦刻尔克不太贴切，因为在敦刻尔克他们并没有死守到底，所以这更像是罗克德里夫特战役之类的吧？我猜是的。除了罗克德里夫特战役中他们最终活下来了……好吧，是的。这是一种高贵的死亡，就像戈登将军那样——我们绝对应该为戈登将军做一期播客。不过更具体地说，这其实深深植根于《伊利亚特》中的伟大英雄阿喀琉斯的追求中。阿喀琉斯曾面临抉择：是选择长寿却默默无闻，还是选择短命但名垂青史。这种“求仁得仁、慷慨赴死”的想法，是希腊人心理中非常重要的一个组成部分。因为他们的文化浸润在荷马史诗的理念之中，而我认为这正是潜藏在这一切背后的本质。
essentially what's lurking behind it because the Spartan kings claim to be descended from the Achaeans who had fought at Troy. And gilding that for Leonidas is the fact that he has this Delphic Oracle where he's been told that unless a Spartan king dies, then the entire city will perish. So in a sense, he's offering himself up as a sacrifice. So that's part of the swirl that the spartans certainly are able to to use to kind of counter the idea that they've been defeated and they have been defeated you know it's a humiliating defeat in one sense their king has died the past has been forced after only two days but you know they can say
因为斯巴达国王自称是曾在特洛伊作战的亚该亚人的后代。为列奥尼达的牺牲镀上一层神圣色彩的是，他曾得到德尔斐神谕的预言：除非有一位斯巴达国王死去，否则整个城邦都将覆灭。从某种意义上说，他是在将自己作为祭品奉献出来。所以，这构成了舆论风暴的一部分。斯巴达人无疑能够利用这一点，来对冲他们战败的屈辱感——从某种意义上说，这确实是一场屈辱的失败：他们的国王阵亡了，仅仅坚守了两天关隘就被迫失守。但他们可以宣称：
well he has died for sparta in every way in defeat he has won in defeat he has won but i think the because i think i think why why do i think themistically plays this role i mean there's the evidence for it is only circumstantial there's no hard evidence for it at all partly it's because he's very very good at spin really really good at spin but it's also because when the Athenians evacuate Attica, that's the essence of the democracy. The democracy makes no sense without being rooted in the soil of Attica. That's what it's all about. The risk is that the Athenians become people without a city and therefore objects of contempt to their fellow Greeks, the Corinthians, the Spartans, the Megarans, people who have not yet lost their cities. And so the idea of sacrifice, that you have to sacrifice something to win, is an important part of the Athenian narrative. And if they compare the sacrifice that Leonidas has made by dying at
“他为了斯巴达而死，虽败犹荣。”在失败中，他赢得了胜利。但我之所以认为地米斯托克利在其中起到了关键作用，是因为——虽然相关的证据大多只是间接的，并没有铁证如山——部分原因在于他非常擅长舆论包装，真的是精通此道的高手。同时也是因为，当雅典人撤离阿提卡时，这正是雅典民主制的精髓所在。如果民主制不扎根于阿提卡的土地，就失去了意义，这才是全部的关键所在。当时面临的风险是，雅典人会变成一群没有国家的人，从而沦为同胞希腊人（如科林斯人、斯巴达人、墨加拉人等尚未失去家园的人）轻蔑的对象。因此，“牺牲”的理念——为了赢得最终的胜利，你必须有所牺牲——构成了雅典人叙事中至关重要的一部分。如果他们将列奥尼达在温泉关慷慨赴死所做出的牺牲，
Thermopylae with the sacrifice that the Athenians are making by evacuating Attica, then that establishes a bond between the Athenians and the Spartans that I think is incredibly important because the risk for Themistocles and the Athenians is that the Spartans who are, you know, and all the Peloponnesians who are naturally very insular will not want to stand and fight at Salamis because they want to defend their own homes on the Peloponnese. And the Peloponnese is the kind of, you know, this, this, this, absolutely, this kind of near island with three prongs that is kind of attached to the mainland of Greece by this very narrow isthmus, this very, very narrow line at Corinth. And what the Peloponnesians are doing rather than marching out to defend Attica
与雅典人撤离阿提卡所做出的牺牲相提并论，这就在雅典人和斯巴达人之间建立了一种极其重要的纽带。因为对地米斯托克利和雅典人来说，最大的风险在于，那些天性孤立的斯巴达人以及所有伯罗奔尼撒人，可能根本不愿意在萨拉米斯死战到底，因为他们更想退回伯罗奔尼撒保卫自己的家园。而伯罗奔尼撒半岛基本上是一个几乎算作岛屿的地方，它有三个向外延伸的半岛夹角，通过一条非常狭窄的地峡——科林斯地峡——与希腊大陆相连。因此，伯罗奔尼撒人并没有主动出击去保卫阿提卡——
which is really what the Athenians would like them to do there's no prospect of another marathon because there aren't enough Athenians to do that to hold off the the the the Persians but also the Peloponnesians are not going to join them because they're building this wall across the isthmus which they're going to defend and they've kind of destroyed this road which is a kind of corniche leading um from athens to to to the isthmus so they're equivalent you know the equivalent of dynamiting it to make sure that the the persian army can't attack it but obviously you can only hold the isthmus if if there is a greek fleet to hold the persian fleet at bay so thermistocles is playing a very very
这本来才是雅典人最希望他们做的事。因为根本不可能再复制一次马拉松大捷，雅典人的人数太少，无力独自抵挡波斯军队。而且伯罗奔尼撒人也不会加入他们，因为伯罗奔尼撒人正在地峡上修筑防线准备据守，甚至还凿毁了那条连接雅典和地峡的沿海悬崖公路。他们的做法就相当于炸毁道路，确保波斯军队无法通过。但显然，只有当存在一支强大的希腊舰队在海上牵制波斯舰队时，你才能守住地峡。所以，地米斯托克利正在下一盘非常艰难的棋。
difficult game because he has to persuade the greek the other greek naval contingents to stand at thermopylae and sorry to stand at salamis and in a sense fight for attica rather than for the peloponnese so creating the myth so creating the myth I think massively helps a last question before we go to a break and after the break we will continue with the narrative so a last question and Russell Hogg he says why did they stay to die um why didn't they just retreat at the end and that is a good question actually so they could have done a sort of fighting retreat couldn't they Leonidas and his men no No, they couldn't because the moment they retreat along the open terrain of Boeotia towards Attica, that's open land. And so Xerxes just has to send his cavalry and his archers and they're dead.
他必须说服希腊其他各城邦的海军分遣队留在萨拉米斯，并为了保卫阿提卡而不是仅仅为了伯罗奔尼撒而战。所以，塑造这个神话至关重要。在我们进入中场休息前的最后一个问题——休息过后我们将继续讲述后面的故事。拉塞尔·霍格提问：“他们当时为什么留下来等死？为什么最后不直接选择撤退呢？”这其实是一个很好的问题。列奥尼达和他的手下本可以进行某种边打边撤的战术，不是吗？不，
Around them, yeah. So it's fight or... Okay, very good. All right. So what Leonidas is doing is he's dying so that they can get away. Yes, very good. So let us leonidas is doing is he's dying so that they can get away yes very good so let us take a break tom and then when we come back we will complete the story which you have set up so brilliantly uh with the battle of salamis and then hopefully at the end if you are nice and brief that is a warning then we will have then we will have time to discuss the cosmic significance of all this
他们做不到。因为一旦他们沿着维奥蒂亚开阔的地形向阿提卡撤退，那就是一马平川的开阔地。薛西斯只需派出他的骑兵和弓箭手，他们就会全部死光。周围全是敌人，对吧？所以他们只能选择死战，或者……好吧，非常棒。所以列奥尼达的选择其实是以死为代价，为其他人争取撤退的时间。是的，非常棒。那么汤姆，我们先休息一下。等我们回来后，你就可以接着讲述那个你用萨拉米斯海战铺垫得如此精彩的故事了。希望到最后，如果你能简明扼要一点的话——这就当是一个善意的提醒——我们还会有时间来探讨这一切宏大的宇宙意义，
and whether it was, after all, a big turning point in world history. So we will see you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment
以及它究竟是不是世界历史上一个巨大的转折点。我们休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、精彩评论、八卦猛料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将为你揭开娱乐产业的幕后运作，
and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are nearing, well, are we nearing the climax of the Persian Wars? We'll find out how quickly Tom Holland can talk. So Thermopylae is over, the Battle of Salamis awaits. Tom, take us into the story. Right, so the Athenians have evacuated Attica. Athens is a ghost city. The only people who hold out are those who have remained on top of the Acropolis. There is this Delphic prophecy, the wooden walls will hold.
告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告内容、加更节目并提前获得现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《The Rest Is History》。我们正在接近——好吧，我们是在接近波斯战争的高潮吗？让我们看看汤姆·霍兰语速能有多快。温泉关之战已经结束，萨拉米斯海战蓄势待发。汤姆，带我们进入这段历史。好的，雅典人已经疏散了阿提卡。雅典成了一座鬼城，唯一坚守的人是那些留在卫城山顶上的人。当时有一个德尔斐预言：“木墙将岿然不动。”
There is a wooden wall around the Acropolis. So the people who hold it, you know, the hope that they can engage and destroy the Persian fleet but it hangs completely in the balance. The Peloponnesians, the Spartans, the Corinthians and so on are very very twitchy about being stuck on an island away from the Peloponnese. So there is a constant risk that what had happened at the Battle of Lade at the end of the Ionian revolt, where the entire Ionian fleet disintegrated, might happen at Salamis. So everything is absolutely in the balance.
卫城周围正围着一圈木墙。因此，坚守那里的人们希望能够交战并摧毁波斯舰队，但局势完全悬于一线。伯罗奔尼撒人、斯巴达人、科林斯人等对被困在一个远离伯罗奔尼撒的岛屿上感到非常不安。因此，始终存在着这样一种风险：当年爱奥尼亚起义末期拉德海战中整个爱奥尼亚舰队崩溃的一幕，可能会在萨拉米斯重演。所以一切都处于千钧一发之际。
Then the Persians arrive. Their cavalry come clattering through the empty streets of Athens. Xerxes arrive. He pitches his great tent at the foot of the Acropolis. The city is looted. Vast swathes of it are burnt. The great trophies of the democracy are crated up to be taken back as booty to Persia. The Persians storm the Acropolis and it is burnt.
随后，波斯人抵达了。他们的骑兵踏着蹄声穿过雅典空旷的街道。薛西斯到了，他在卫城脚下扎下了巨大的御营。这座城市遭到洗劫，大片城区被付之一炬。民主制的伟大纪念品被装箱打包，作为战利品运回波斯。波斯人对卫城发起强攻，卫城燃起了大火。
It's torched. amazing symbolism i mean most devastating symbolism for the greeks who can see it from salamis so the view to athens is blocked off by a great mountain but they can see the smoke rising and they know what's happening yeah and again of course this just is terrible for morale and so you have this there is constant debate let's put it like that on salamis about what they should do should they skedaddle to the peloponnese or should they stay and fight and you can guarantee that there are agents on salamis working for the persians because that's what always happens and so it is being reported back to xerxes that you know there's every prospect that the peloponnesians and Athenians are going to fall apart and you can
惨遭烈火吞噬。这具有惊人的象征意义——对于那些从萨拉米斯远眺的希腊人来说，这是最具毁灭性的象征。通往雅典的视线被一座大山阻挡，但他们能看到滚滚浓烟升起，他们心里清楚发生了什么。是的，这当然对士气造成了沉重的打击。因此，在萨拉米斯岛上，关于下一步该怎么做，始终争论不休：他们到底是应该溜之大吉逃往伯罗奔尼撒，还是留下来死战到底？你可以确信，萨拉米斯岛上一定潜伏着为波斯人效力的间谍，这种事在历史上屡见不鲜。因此，各种情报源源不断地汇报给薛西斯，称伯罗奔尼撒人和雅典人内部随时可能彻底分裂。你可以
bet that that gold is being offered to to foster divisions so it's it's a real challenge for Themistocles and those who want to fight at Salamis but it is also a challenge for Xerxes because he now it's it it's now late September autumn is drawing in uh and you remember from the uh the Delphic Oracle Divine Salamis you will be the ruin of many a mother's son when the seed is scattered all the harvest is gathered in we've now reached the harvest age so it looks like the crisis point is emerging now what should Xerxes do Demaratus the Spartan who understands his own people, he knows exactly what the Spartans would least want. And so he says, send your fleet, divide it in two
断定，波斯人正在挥舞着金银财宝来挑拨离间。这对地米斯托克利以及那些想要在萨拉米斯决战的人来说是一个巨大的挑战，但对薛西斯而言同样是个挑战。因为现在已经是九月下旬，秋意渐浓。你还记得德尔斐神谕的谶语吗？“神圣的萨拉米斯，你将成为无数母亲丧子的悲伤之地，当种子播撒，秋收完毕之时。”现在正是收获的季节，危机似乎已经迫在眉睫。薛西斯该怎么做？斯巴达人德玛拉图斯十分了解他自己的人民，他深知斯巴达人最不愿看到的是什么。于是他建议：“派遣你的舰队，将其一分为二，
and send half of it to attack the Peloponnese. And that will split the Greek fleet. But Xerxes doesn't want to do that because he now doesn't have enough troops really to do that. If he divides his fleet in two, then that that remains could be defeated and he can't risk that. Because he's lost ships to Poseidon yes because of the business with the sea exactly exactly
派出一半去进攻伯罗奔尼撒。”这将会分散希腊舰队的兵力。但薛西斯并不想这么做，因为他现在手头的兵力确实不够充裕了。如果他把舰队一分为二，剩下的部分可能会被各个击破，他冒不起这个险。因为他之前已经因为海神波塞冬发怒而损失了许多战舰。正是如此，正是如此。
artemisia who is the queen of halicarnassus the city from which herodotus comes which is why she has such a high profile in his history she says don't engage with them at all just sit it out uh you know winter's coming stay here for winter uh that it will all disintegrate that's what i'd have done but xerxes can't because he's the king of the world and he doesn't want to be stuck in athens you know it would be like the american president spending the winter in napoleon in moscow napoleon moscow can't do that so he doesn't want to do that so he wants to engage so what he does is he he basically waits for for the Greek fleet to come out of the straits because he doesn't want to fight in the narrow straits that separate Attica from Salamis. So, he waits and he waits and nothing happens.
阿尔忒弥西亚——来自哈利卡纳索斯（希罗多德的故乡）的女国王，这也是她在希罗多德史书中备受瞩目的原因——她建议：“绝对不要跟他们正面交战，按兵不动即可。冬天的脚步近了，在这里过冬，他们自己就会土崩瓦解的。”如果是我，我就会这么做。但薛西斯贵为世界之王，他做不到这一点，他可不想一直困在雅典。这就好比美国总统把整个冬天耗在莫斯科的拿破仑身上一样。拿破仑都没能做到在莫斯科过冬，薛西斯也无法接受。所以他不想采取这种拖延战术，他渴望决战。于是他采取的策略是，静静等待希腊舰队主动驶出海峡，因为他自己并不想开进分隔阿提卡与萨拉米斯的狭窄海峡中去作战。因此，他只能等待，不断地等待，然而什么也没有发生。
And so, it's a game of cat and mouse. And what Themistocles does is that he turns the Persian command of espionage against them and again this it's very difficult to be entirely sure what happens because the sources are you know we have a play by the tragedian Aeschylus we have Herodotus's account both are quite confused neither goes into entirely the amount of detail you would that one would want but i think that you can just about kind of distinguish that that what what decides salamis is an intelligence war where you've got double agents out thinking each other and basically what thermistically needs to do is to get the persian fleet into the straits and the way that he does that I think is that he basically
所以，这是一场猫鼠游戏。地米斯托利斯所做的，是将波斯的间谍指挥反过来对付他们。这里再次说明，我们很难百分之百确定当时发生了什么，因为史料来源……你知道的，我们有悲剧作家埃斯库罗斯的戏剧，还有希罗多德的记载，两者都有点混乱，谁都没有提供人们想要的全部细节。但我认为，你勉强可以分辨出，决定萨拉米斯之战胜负的是一场情报战，双面间谍在斗智斗勇，而地米斯托利斯基本上需要做的是把波斯舰队引入海峡，他实现这一目的的方法，我认为，基本上是
tells Xerxes not only what he is expecting to hear but what he he is desperate to hear which is that the Athenians are actually prepared to to change sides that the Peloponnesians are going to betray them anyway, so they might as well try and get as good terms as they can. And what we do know is that the tutor of Themistocles' son, a slave called Sicinus, goes across in a little shipping, a little rowing boat, across the straits, where he's welcomed by Persian agents. He's taken directly to the Persian king.
他不仅告诉薛西斯薛西斯期望听到的话，而且告诉薛西斯他极度渴望听到的话，那就是雅典人其实准备倒戈了，伯罗奔尼撒人无论如何都会背叛他们，所以他们不妨尽量争取最好的条件。我们所知道的是，地米斯托利斯儿子的家庭教师，一个名叫西西努斯的奴隶，坐着一艘小货船、一艘小划艇穿过海峡，在那里受到了波斯特工的欢迎。他被直接带到了波斯国王面前。
He then, Sickinus says, Themistocles, the Athenian admiral, wants you to win. The Peloponnesians are about to run away. They're plotting to go out from the straits, out into the open ocean. All that you have to do is to send your fleet out and you'll catch them red-handed. And then Sycenaeus goes back. Xerxes takes the bait. He sends his fleet out. They occupy the exit from the straits. They wait there all night.
接着，西西努斯说：“雅典舰队司令地米斯托利斯希望你们赢。伯罗奔尼撒人快要逃跑了。他们正密谋从海峡撤退，逃到公海上去。你只需要把舰队派出去，就会当场抓获他们。”然后西西努斯就回去了。薛西斯上钩了。他把舰队派了出去。他们占据了海峡的出口。他们在那里等了一整夜。
The Peloponnesians don't come. Xerxes has his throne put up on the mountain heights, the rocky prow that looks a seaborne salamis to watch what he is hoping will be the sight of the peloponnesians trying to escape that's always fatal isn't it when you when you put your throne up to watch a battle it it always ends in tears he does not so so what what then happens we're not entirely sure but but essentially at dawn, with Xerxes sat on his throne, the Persian fleet starts to go into the straits. Why do they do that? Perhaps it's because they're kind of preemptively deciding this is what Xerxes wants. Or perhaps it's because Xerxes gives the order.
伯罗奔尼撒人没有来。薛西斯让人把他的王座搬到了山高处，那个俯瞰海上的萨拉米斯岛的岩石岬角上，准备观看他所期望的场景——伯罗奔尼撒人试图逃跑。每当你把王座搬去观看一场战斗时，结果总是悲剧收场，不是吗？总是以眼泪告终。他没有看到。那么，接下来发生了什么？我们并不是完全确定，但基本上在黎明时分，随着薛西斯坐在他的王座上，波斯舰队开始驶入海峡。他们为什么这样做？也许是因为他们出于某种先发制人的心理，认为这就是薛西斯想要的；或者也许是因为薛西斯下达了命令。
And why would Xerxes give the order well as he looks down he can see that a contingent of ships which is actually the corinthian contingent is sailing not not out immediately out of the straits but around the island of salamis he's kind of going down the coast from salamis yeah and the reason for this is that um maybe the persians have as they actually have done they've sent the egyptian contingent to block off the exit that lies kind of eight miles along the island of Salamis and so Xerxes thinks are what what Themistocles had told me happening is now happening they're sailing into a trap let's go in and get them so the Persian fleet sails in but they discover to their horror that the Athenian that the Greek fleet is not disintegrating that the Peloponnesians and the Athenians the Corinthians the Megarans
为什么薛西斯会下达命令呢？当他往下看时，他可以看到有一支舰队——实际上是科林斯的舰队——没有直接驶出海峡，而是绕着萨拉米斯岛航行，他可以说是沿着萨拉米斯岛的海岸往下走。是的，这样做的原因可能是，也许波斯人已经像他们实际做的那样，派出了埃及舰队去封锁距离萨拉米斯岛约八英里处的出口。因此薛西斯心想：“啊，地米斯托利斯告诉我正在发生的事现在正发生着，他们正驶入陷阱，我们进去抓住他们吧。”于是波斯舰队驶入，但他们惊恐地发现，雅典——希腊舰队并没有瓦解，伯罗奔尼撒人和雅典人、科林斯人、墨加拉人，
everybody are a coherent body and they sail out to meet the Persian fleet they back away they back away drawing the Persians in and in and in and then it is said a great voice a woman's voice is heard echoing out across the strait saying, fools, why do you withdraw? Why do you withdraw? Attack. The Greek fleet sails forward, smashes into the side of the Persian flotillas and bunches them up. And exactly what the Greeks had wanted,
所有人都是一个有凝聚力的整体，他们驶出来迎战波斯舰队。他们后退，他们后退，把波斯人引进来，引进来，再引进来。然后据说海峡中回荡起了一个巨大的声音，一个女人的声音，喊着：“傻瓜们，你们为什么退缩？你们为什么退缩？进攻！”希腊舰队向前驶去，猛烈撞击波斯舰队的侧翼，把他们挤成一团。这正是希腊人一直想要的，
which is to make sure that the Persian weight of numbers is turned against them, because now their oars are snagging. They're smashing into each other. And the Greek fleet can just pick them off. Tom, who was the woman? Athena. What are you going to tell us? Athena.
那就是确保波斯庞大的数量优势反过来对付他们自己，因为现在他们的船桨卡住了。他们互相撞击。而希腊舰队可以从容地把他们各个击破。汤姆，那个女人是谁？是雅典娜。你要告诉我们什么？是雅典娜。
Demeter. Nemesis. I mean, who knows? We don't know. We don't know. But that day in subsequent Greek renderings has the quality of myth. Yes. It's said that, you know, the shadowy forms of heroes are there, that a great serpent is seen swimming alongside the Greek fleet.
是得墨忒耳。是涅墨西斯。我是说，谁知道呢？我们不知道。我们不知道。但在后来的希腊人渲染中，那一天的战斗具有了神话的色彩。是的。据说，你知道，英雄们模糊的身影出现在那里，一条巨蛇被看到跟随着希腊舰队游动。
There is the sense that this is a conflict fit to rank with, you know, the battle fought on the plains of troy and at the end of the day the persian fleet is shattered their ships are you know masts and jet flotsam and jetsam um and one half of the amphibious operation that xerxes has brought to conquer the Greeks has been effectively put out of action. And this isn't the end of the Persian invasion. Xerxes himself, you know, he's seen enough. He doesn't want to spend the winter in this kind of ghastly place. So he goes back across the Aegean
人们有一种感觉，这场冲突足以与在特洛伊平原上进行的战斗相提并论。到了那天结束时，波斯舰队粉碎了，他们的船只——你知道的，桅杆和漂浮的残骸——随波漂流，薛西斯为征服希腊而带来的一半两栖作战部队实际上已经失去了战斗力。这并不是波斯入侵的结束。薛西斯本人，你知道的，他已经看够了。他不想在这个可怕的地方过冬。所以他穿过爱琴海回去了，
and he returns to Persepolis. But he leaves a very substantial military force in Greece. You know, he's taken away his levies but he's left the kind of crack squad and the following year the Spartans and the other Peloponnesians are persuaded by the Athenians that if they don't come and basically confront this force and rescue Athens then the Athenians will go over to the Persians so a great land force joins they meet at Plataea you know the little city that had been standing by Athens throughout and there they defeat the Persians in 479 and that effectively is is the end of the Persian war and it is for the Greeks what the second world war is for the British it's the
返回了波斯波利斯。但他留下了相当规模的军事力量在希腊。你知道的，他撤走了征召兵，但留下了精锐部队。第二年，斯巴达人和其他伯罗奔尼撒人被雅典人说服，如果他们不来正面对抗这支部队并拯救雅典，那么雅典人就会倒戈投降波斯人。于是，一支庞大的陆军集结起来，他们在普拉提亚会师——那个自始至终坚定支持雅典的小城——并在那里于公元前479年击败了波斯人。这实际上就是波斯战争的结束，对希腊人来说，这就如同第二次世界大战对英国人一样，是一场
great victory and just as the British never stopped going on about the second world war so the Athenians and the Spartans never stopped going on about the persian war and all right those who were on the wrong side which included the thebans are never allowed to forget it so before we get into the significance of the legacy a couple of questions from listeners about the the battle of salamis itself so ramzi nora says um who were the better sailors the persians in brackets, Phoenicians. Presumably there must have been an awful lot of Phoenicians. They're obviously brilliant sailors and Xerxes must have relied on them.
伟大的胜利。正如英国人对二战津津乐道永无止境一样，雅典人和斯巴达人对波斯战争也同样津津乐道永无止境。好吧，那些站在错误一边的人（其中包括底比斯人）永远不被允许忘记这件事。所以在我们进入遗产的重要意义之前，先回答听众关于萨拉米斯战役本身的几个问题。拉姆齐·诺拉（Ramzi Nora）问：谁是更好的水手？括号里的波斯人，腓尼基人。想必一定有非常多的腓尼基人。他们显然是出色的水手，薛西斯一定很依赖他们。
Or the Greeks. I thought the former, i.e. the Phoenicians, had more of an impressive range of maritime achievements. So are the Greeks going into this as underdogs, sort of in maritime terms? Yeah, definitely. The Phoenicians are absolutely the best um the the the egyptians are very good as well and the iranians of course are very good the whole thing about the um you know they're very good so the corinthians are excellent
还是希腊人？我原以为前者，即腓尼基人，拥有更令人印象深刻的一系列海上成就。所以希腊人进入这场战役时是处于劣势吗，就海上实力而言？是的，绝对是。腓尼基人绝对是最棒的，埃及人也非常优秀，伊朗人当然也很优秀，关于他们的整体情况……你知道的，他们非常优秀。所以科林斯人非常出色，
and they've basically perfected the trireme which is this um kind of it's like a kind of, if you imagine a spear on water with three banks of oars, invented by the Phoenicians but perfected by the Corinthians. So the Corinthians are very, very good. I mean, the Athenians have only had three years to practice. So in a way, Tom, the way they win the Battle of Salamis is by negating all of the maritime accomplishments, the nautical accomplishments of the persian essentially they basically turn it almost into a land battle do they by concentrating no they don't no so it's not like the romans do against the carthaginians where that that is the roman strategy
他们基本上完善了三列桨战船，这种船就像是……如果你想象一根水中的矛，有三排桨，由腓尼基人发明，但由科林斯人完善。所以科林斯人非常非常优秀。我的意思是，雅典人只有三年时间练习。所以在某种程度上，汤姆，他们赢得萨拉米斯之战的方式，是通过抵消波斯人的所有海上成就、航海成就，本质上他们几乎把它变成了一场陆战，是这样吗？通过集中……不，他们没有，不。所以这不像罗马人对迦太基人那样，那是罗马人的战略。
yeah the athenians have been practicing very hard and they are able to use the ram to destroy at the head of the prow of the ship to destroy the um these other ships because they've become bunched up so they win by so the athenians are good the athenians you know they have been practicing hard it's all they've been doing for three years so they are i mean they're not absolutely as elite as the phoenicians are but they're pretty good um the plateans um you know at the beginning of the um you know before thermlae, they've come and they've offered their services. And the Athenians are always in the need of rowers. And so they, the Plataeans kind of try and do it.
是的，雅典人一直在非常努力地练习，他们能够利用撞角在船头摧毁……摧毁这些其他船只，因为波斯船只挤成了一团。所以他们赢了……所以雅典人很厉害，雅典人（你知道的）他们一直在刻苦练习，这是他们三年来一直在做的事。所以他们……我的意思是，他们虽然不像腓尼基人那样绝对精锐，但他们相当不错。普拉提亚人（你知道的）在……在……在温泉关之战前，他们就来了，并提供他们的服务。雅典人总是需要划船手。所以他们，普拉提亚人试图参与进来。
And Herodotus says that, you know, that their enthusiasm to help was greater than their ability to help. That's funny. So, so, so. Yes, thank you. Thank you. But no, thank you. Basically, with Pl pretty, pretty. And Rose.
希罗多德说，（你知道的）他们帮忙的热情大于他们帮忙的能力。真搞笑。所以，所以，所以。是的，谢谢。谢谢。但不用了，谢谢。基本上，对普拉提亚人来说，相当……相当……还有罗斯。
OK, so next question from Fordeck and Shabby. I don't know if that's two different people. Anyway, it's about Themistocles. Could the Greeks have beaten off the Persians without Themistocles? And is there a historical parallel between Themistocles? Well, we've kind of alluded to this, I think, in the last episode, Themistocles and Churchill. So could the Greeks won without Themistocles the last episode themistocles and churchill so could the greeks won without themistocles and is themistocles churchill i i think that um i mean he's a cross between churchill and odysseus wow that's a great cross he that's great he looks what a great thing to say about the statues of him he looks like he looks like churchill he has this kind of bulldog yeah kind of big
好的，接下来的问题来自福代克（Fordeck）和沙比（Shabby）。我不知道这是否是两个人。总之，这是关于地米斯托利斯的。如果没有地米斯托利斯，希腊人能击退波斯人吗？地米斯托利斯和谁之间是否存在历史相似性？好吧，我们在上一集里其实已经提到过了，我认为，地米斯托利斯和丘吉尔。所以如果没有地米斯托利斯，希腊人能赢吗？上一集讲的是地米斯托利斯和丘吉尔。所以如果没有地米斯托利斯，希腊人能赢吗？地米斯托利斯就是丘吉尔吗？我想，我的意思是，他是丘吉尔和奥德修斯的结合体。哇，真是个绝妙的结合！他……太棒了。他看起来……关于他的雕像，有什么好说的呢？他看起来像……他看起来像丘吉尔。他有一种……这种斗牛犬般的……是的，那种大大的、
bulldog kind of expression like champagne and silk pajamas we don't know that but he he i mean he's an absolute piece of work he's he schemes he backstabs i mean he ends up going over to the persians i mean he'll betray anyone anyone that he can you know very like Odysseus but I think he does I mean I think insofar as you know the sources that we have I think that he plays absolutely the key role and I think that I think he saves I think he saves his city and I think he saves Greece okay and I think you know it's very difficult because of, there is always a tendency on the part. You know, we have a biography of him by Plutarch, which is the most detailed account of his life. He doesn't feature very strongly in Herodotus because he had so many enemies.
斗牛犬般的表情，喜欢香槟和丝绸睡衣——我们不知道这一点，但他……我的意思是，他绝对是个厉害角色。他密谋，他背后捅刀子——我的意思是，他最后甚至投奔了波斯人。我的意思是，他会背叛任何人，任何他能背叛的人（你知道的），非常像奥德修斯。但我认为他确实……我的意思是，就我们拥有的史料而言，我认为他发挥了绝对关键的作用。我认为他……我认为他拯救了他的城市，我认为他拯救了希腊。好吧，我认为（你知道的）这非常困难，因为……总是有一种倾向。你知道的，我们有一本普鲁塔克为他写的传记，这是对他生平最详细的记载。他在希罗多德的著作中并没有占据很突出的地位，因为他有太多的敌人。
And clearly the sources that Herodotus is drawing on don't want to big him up. But even even they can't deny the kind of outsized role that he played um so there is of course there's a tendency to to focus on the individual uh perhaps at the expense of the collective in in the sources but i i do having said that i mean yes i think that churchill is the obvious comparison all right well let's get down to to the some of the real big questions. So Richard Delevan says, what would have happened if Persia had won at Salamis? So in other words, is this a winnable war for Persia? And what does that mean?
显然，希罗多德取材的史料并不想把他的形象放大。但即使是这样，他们也无法否认他所发挥的巨大作用。所以，当然，史料中有一种倾向，即过分关注个人，而可能牺牲了集体。话虽如此，我的意思是，是的，我认为丘吉尔是一个显而易见的对比。好吧，让我们来探讨一些真正重大而宏观的问题。理查德·德拉文（Richard Delevan）问：如果波斯人在萨拉米斯获胜，会发生什么？换句话说，对波斯人来说，这是一场能够打赢的战争吗？那意味着什么？
Does that mean that do they bother incorporating mainland Greece into the Persian empire? Or do they just, you know, sort of sow the fields with salt and then go home? Or what's the end game from the Persian perspective? Well, this is a question that Herodotus asks. I think we mentioned this on the episode on counterfactuals, that the very first counterfactual is exactly this. You've written an essay about this, haven't you? Yeah. So Herodotus says, I mean, he's talking about, he's writing at a time where the Athenians basically have replaced the Persians as the big bad boy on the block.
那是否意味着他们会费心把希腊本土并入波斯帝国？还是他们只是，你知道的，在田地里撒盐然后回家？或者从波斯的角度来看，最终的目标是什么？好吧，这是希罗多德提出的一个问题。我想我们在反事实历史那一集里提到过，最早的反事实假设正是这个。你写过一篇关于这个的文章，对吧？是的。所以希罗多德说——我的意思是，他在谈论……他写作的时代，雅典人基本上已经取代了波斯人，成为了当地的大恶霸。
And so the Athenians aren't very popular with other Greeks. And Herodotus says, my controversial opinion is that the Athenians, you know, the Athenians did it. And the reason for that is that without their fleet, the Persians would have been able to just land troops on the Peloponnese. And so the wall across the Isthmus at Corinth would have been useless. And Herodotus gives it as his opinion that the Spartans would have been wiped out after performing prodigies of valor. And that would have been that. And Greece would have become a Persian province. And I'm pretty sure that is exactly what would have happened. It would have become a Persian province. And I'm pretty sure that is exactly what would have happened.
所以雅典人在其他希腊人中并不太受欢迎。希罗多德说：“我颇具争议的观点是，雅典人……你知道的，雅典人做到了。”原因在于，如果没有他们的舰队，波斯人就能直接把军队送上伯罗奔尼撒半岛。因此，科林斯地峡上的那堵墙就形同虚设了。希罗多德给出的观点是，斯巴达人在表现出惊人的英勇之后将被消灭。事情就会是这样。希腊将成为波斯的一个省。我非常确信这正是会发生的事情。希腊将成为波斯的一个省。我非常确信这正是会发生的事情。
It would have become a Persian satrapy, basically. Yeah, because, as we said at the beginning of episode one, there are lots of cities that are very keen to welcome the Persians. You know, the Thebans would be delighted to see the Athenians wiped out. And lots of people in the Peloponnese who were subject to Sparta would you know again be delighted to see the Spartans eliminated as well and particularly of course the helots the the Messenians the people who've been enslaved by the by the Spartans I mean what it would what the Persians would have done is is what the Thebans in due course a hundred years
基本上会成为波斯的一个行省。是的，因为正如我们在第一集开头所说的那样，有许多城市非常热衷于欢迎波斯人。你知道的，底比斯人会很高兴看到雅典人被消灭；伯罗奔尼撒半岛上有许多受斯巴达统治的人，你知道的，同样会很高兴看到斯巴达人也被消灭，尤其是黑劳士，那些美西尼亚人，那些被斯巴达人奴役的人。我的意思是，波斯人会做的事，就是底比斯人在不久之后的一百年里
later do which is to to set the helots free and establish them as a kind of, you know, a city in their own right. So that's, I'm sure, what the Persians would have done because the whole way that the Persians deal with the Greeks is to divide and rule. Okay, so we've got 10 to 15 minutes left and I want to kick off the discussion
所做的事，那就是解放黑劳士，让他们建立为一个独立的城市。所以，我确信波斯人会这样做，因为波斯人对付希腊人的整个方式就是分而治之。好了，我们还剩10到15分钟，我想以听众提出的两个问题来开启讨论，我会把它们都读出来。首先是Joshua D. Terry，节目的老朋友。他说：
with two questions from our listeners and I'll read them both out. So first of all, Joshua D. Terry, friend of the show. He says, I once read a counterfactual essay arguing that the Battle of Salamis saved Western civilization. That sounds very Tom Holland, I have to say. Do you agree that Persian victory would have prevented the Simpsons from ever happening, i.e. Western civilization? Now, before you answer that, just a second. I'll read the second one as well. Stefan Jensen, another friend of the show, he says, did the Greek victory over the Persians matter at all? Would we have been speaking Farsi
我曾经读过一篇反事实的历史论文，争论说萨拉米斯之战拯救了西方文明。这听得真非常“汤姆·霍兰”，我必须这么说。你是否同意，如果波斯人获胜，就会阻止《辛普森一家》的诞生，也就是阻止西方文明的出现？现在，在你回答之前，等一下。我也把第二个问题读出来。Stefan Jensen，节目的另一位朋友，他说：希腊人对波斯的胜利到底有没有意义？如果不是因为列奥尼达的300勇士，难道我们全欧洲现在都会说波斯语吗？还是说这只是对希腊人极其重要，但在宏大的历史格局中其实并没有多大意义？所以，这就是Joshua D. Terry的观点：没有《星球大战》，没有《辛普森一家》，没有西方文明。Stefan Jensen则说：嗯，谁在乎呢？这只对希腊人重要，对其他任何人都没有真正的影响。那么你的立场是什么？现在，汤姆，你的书《波斯之火》，副标题是什么，是什么来着？
all over Europe if it weren't for Leonidas' Brave 300? Or was it just hugely important for the Greeks, but not very significant in the great scheme of things? So there you have Joshua D. Terry, who says no Star Wars, no Simpsons, no Western civilization. Stefan Jensen says, well, who cares? It only matters for the Greeks. It doesn't really matter for anybody else. So where do you stand? Now, Tom, your book, Persian Fire, is called, the subtitle is, what is it?
第一大帝国与……第一帝国与对西方的争夺。与对西方的争夺。是的。我的意思是，显然，我……第一帝国与对西方的争夺，以及对西方的争夺。是的。我的意思是，显然，这是一个矛盾的书名，因为当然，对西方的争夺是指波斯帝国的西方，嗯，不一定只是西方，因为，因为正如我所说，西方是希腊和波斯双重影响的结合体。是的，回答这个问题的一个方法是说，爱奥尼亚人，他们基本上……
The First World War and the... First World Empire and the Battle for the West. And the Battle for the West. Yeah. I mean, obviously, I... the first world empire and the battle for the west and the battle for the west yeah i mean obviously i it's an ambivalent title because of course there's a the battle for the west is the west of the persian empire well not necessarily the west because because because as i've said the west is a compound of both greek and persian influences yes and one one way to answer that question is to say that the ionians who essentially it's the
爱奥尼亚是哲学和科学的发源地，泰勒斯、赫拉克利特以及所有这些内容，也就是所谓的爱奥尼亚启蒙运动，你知道的，那是在波斯统治下发生的。所以希腊人在波斯的统治下完全可以做他们自己的事情。与此相对的是，我认为雅典有一些非常独特的东西，如果没有它，民主制度就不会像后来在伯里克利统治下那样运作，雅典的黄金时代在波斯统治下也不会发生，雅典可能也不会……你知道的，我的意思是，它会被消灭，米利都的命运将会降临到雅典头上，是的，
but ionia is the birthplace of philosophy so and science vales and heraclitus and all that kind of stuff the ionian enlightenment as it's called um you know that happens under persian rule so it's perfectly possible for greeks to do their stuff under under under persian dominance um against that i think that there's something very distinctive about athens that would so the democracy would not have been fun would not have functioned as it goes on to function under pericles um and the golden age of athens under persian rule and athens would probably not have you know i mean it would it would have been wiped out the the fate of miletus would have been visited on athens um yeah uh it's you know the men would have been slaughtered the the women and and children enslaved um so there would have
你知道的，男人们会被屠杀，妇女和儿童会被沦为奴隶。所以将不会有苏格拉底，不会有柏拉图，
been no socrates there would have been no plato um there would have been no aristophanes there would have been no ischolus there would have been there would have been no aristophanes there would have been no ischolus there would have been there would have been no drama why not because the drama isn't it that the tragedies the comedies are a function of the democracy they don't they couldn't happen in a non-democratic greek no because it's it's dependent that they are they are a kind of organic part of of what it is to be an athenian in a democracy that's that's how they evolve okay so you could say well you know the lack of tragedy or comedy perhaps doesn't you know so what but i i do think that um the the influence of greek philosophy
不会有阿里斯托芬，不会有埃斯库罗斯，不会有阿里斯托芬，不会有埃斯库罗斯，不会有戏剧。为什么不会？因为戏剧——难道悲剧、喜剧不是民主制度的产物吗？它们不可能在一个非民主的希腊发生。不，因为它们是相互依存的，它们是有机的一部分，构成了民主制度下的雅典人，它们就是这样演变而来的。好吧，所以你可以说，嗯，你知道的，缺乏悲剧或喜剧也许并不会……所以那又怎样？但我确实认为，希腊哲学的影响，
and specifically socrates and plato and aristotle but is it not the case that um that as you said yourself all the Ionian cities have great thinkers and they have great philosophers who flourish? The other thing, if I can just make a couple of other, offer a couple of other incoherent thoughts. One is obviously Alexandria plays a huge part a couple of hundred years later in the sort of dissemination of Greek thought. And that happens under a monarchy that equates itself with divinity, the Ptolemaic kingdom. Yes, it does.
特别是苏格拉底、柏拉图和亚里士多德的影响……但难道事实不是这样吗，正如你自己所说，所有的爱奥尼亚城市都有伟大的思想家，都有繁荣的哲学家？另一件事——如果我能再表达几个其他的不太连贯的想法的话——一个是，亚历山大在几百年后对希腊思想的传播起到了巨大的作用。而那是在一个将自己等同于神明的君主制下发生的，也就是托勒密王国。是的，确实如此。
And also Persian and Greek. There is a synthesis of Persian and Greek ideas anyway in the years after the Persian war. In the form of Christianity and then Islam. But I think that without the specific traditions of Athenian philosophy, I doubt that would have happened. There would, for instance, it's very improbable that Alexander's conquests would have happened. Why? Well, because because if if Persia has occupied Greece, then I mean, it's perfectly possible that there would be rebellions equivalent to the Ionian revolt. Perhaps in due course, the Persians would have had to do, you know, in Americaenian democracy and all the kind of the incredible cultural trends that flows from that you know that would have gone and presumably the framework of the Macedonian monarchy that ends up giving us Philip and then Alexander would also be neutered at the very least so essentially you would you know that you wouldn't
而且波斯和希腊的想法在波斯战争之后的几年里也已经有了融合。以基督教和后来的伊斯兰教的形式。但我认为，如果没有雅典哲学的独特传统，我怀疑这一切都不会发生。例如，亚历山大的征服极不可能发生。为什么？嗯，因为如果波斯占领了希腊，那么——我的意思是，完全有可能出现相当于爱奥尼亚起义的叛乱。也许在适当的时候，波斯人不得不去……你知道的，雅典民主制以及由此产生的所有不可思议的文化潮流，都会烟消云散，而最终给我们带来腓力然后是亚历山大的马其顿君主制的框架，至少也会被废掉。所以本质上，你不会
have had the hellenistic world you wouldn't have had the world of of that follows alexander but you would have had something could you not argue though tom the persians win the the persian the greek-persian wars they create a sort of i don't, I want to say Pax Persiana or something in the sort of Eastern Mediterranean and so on. So at the end of, at the point where BC gives way to AD, the same synthesis of kind of Greek, Egyptian, Persian ideas is... I'm sure, yes, absolutely. Yes, I'm sure that would have happened.
拥有希腊化世界，不会拥有亚历山大之后的世界，但你会拥有某种东西。汤姆，你难道不能这样争辩吗：如果波斯人赢了波斯希腊战争，他们会在东地中海等地创造一种类似“波斯和平”的东西。所以在公元前向公元后过渡的那个时间点，希腊、埃及、波斯思想的那种融合也同样会……我确信，是的，绝对会。是的，我确信那会发生。
But it's just that the form the synthesis takes would have been would have been different but it wouldn't have been necessarily worse would it that's my i suppose my point i don't know i mean so well but you see i think our ability to judge what would be worse would have changed all right well that's a very big claim because our entire framework our framework well you know our assumption for instance that democracy is a good thing would not exist because the democracy would have been wiped out. But we don't think that.
但只是这种融合的形式会有所不同，但这并不一定意味着更糟糕，对吧？我想这大概是我的观点。我不知道，我的意思是，好吧……但你看，我认为我们判断什么更糟糕的能力会发生改变。好吧，这是一个非常宏大的断言，因为我们的整个框架，我们的框架——你知道的，例如我们认为民主是一件好事这一假设将不复存在，因为民主会被消灭。但我们不这样认为。
You see, I don't think... There's an assumption sometimes among particularly... I hope I'm not going to alienate loads of listeners. Particularly kind of American thinkers of a particular kind of political disposition that, you know, we're the heirs of athenian democracy and all this stuff but i always think you can't draw a sort of direct line because we're not the roman empire and all those things come in between we should do an episode on democracy because that's absolutely not the case the democracy
你看，我不认为……有时候人们有一种假设，特别是在……我希望我不会疏远一大批听众，特别是一些特定政治倾向的美国思想家，他们认为，你知道的，我们是雅典民主的继承者等等。但我总是认为，你不能画出一条直接的线，因为我们不是罗马帝国，所有这些中间环节都介入了。我们应该做一集关于民主的节目，因为绝对不是这样的——民主
and it won't surprise you to hear me say this the democracy we have is rooted in christianity it doesn't surprise me christian assumption the athenian democracy is radically different yeah but that so we'd still have got to where we got to even if there was no athenian democracy no we wouldn't we wouldn't because because we we don't know what form you know presumably some kind of synthesis would have happened but we don't know that it would necessarily be the synthesis that that in the event emerged and a world in which you don't have christianity and islam is a radically different one i mean maybe you might still have had monotheisms tom you might yes you might but we don't know and the forms that it would have taken would have been different
（听到我这么说你不会感到惊讶）我们拥有的民主植根于基督教，这并不让我感到惊讶，这是基督教的假设。雅典的民主是截然不同的。是的，但即便没有雅典民主，我们最终还是会走到今天这一步。不，我们不会，我们不会的，因为我们不知道会以什么形式（你知道的），也许某种形式的融合会发生，但我们不知道那是否一定会是最终涌现出来的融合，一个没有基督教和伊斯兰教的世界将是一个截然不同的世界。我的意思是，也许你可能仍然会有某种一神论，汤姆，你可能会的。是的，你可能会，但我们不知道，它所采取的形式将会是不同的。
okay i i just think that you know it's it's and and saying the world would be you know better or worse well he can't the standard the standards by which we would judge what is good or bad better or worse are themselves determined by the fact that the greeks did win the battle of salamis i would argue fair enough let me just change the question a tiny bit then should we when we tell the story of the persian wars we always tell it from the greek perspective so ali ansari if he's listening to this steaming with rage must be absolutely no he's very i i when i advertised this on twitter i put a picture of the uh a kind of modern illustration of the greeks winning the battle of salamis and he wittily responded with a picture of the persians burning Athens so it's all good sport but so so you know almost without
好吧，我只是认为（你知道的）这是……而且说世界会变得更好或更糟，好吧，你不能……我们用来判断什么是好或坏、更好或更糟的标准本身，是由希腊人在萨拉米斯之战中获胜这一事实决定的，我会这样争辩。有道理。那我把问题稍微改一点点：当我们讲述波斯战争的故事时，我们总是从希腊人的角度来讲述。所以阿里·安萨里（Ali Ansari）如果正在听这个节目，一定会气得冒烟，绝对会……不，他非常……当我把这个发到推特上宣传时，我配了一张现代插图，画的是希腊人赢得萨拉米斯之战，而他机智地回复了一张波斯人焚烧雅典的照片。所以这都是很好的消遣。所以，几乎无一例外地，我们从希腊人的角度来讲述这个故事，而且人们总是把它讲成是一个善恶对决的故事——我的意思是，他们真的这么做。300勇士弗兰克·米勒的漫画书和电影，就是把它拍成善恶之战，拍成好人与坏人的对抗，这稍微有点不同。好吧，好人与坏人，那么好吧，希腊人是热爱自由的坚毅农夫（你知道的，他们有点像罗素·克劳式的银幕形象），而波斯人则因穷奢极欲而腐化，他们残忍，他们带有东方色彩，他们是纯粹的东方主义幻想。你对这些说法有什么赞同的吗？还是你认为这个故事中存在道德维度，或者根本没有？
exception we tell the story from the greek perspective and we tell and people always tell us as a story of good and evil i mean they really do the 300 frank miller comic book and film they do it as good good and evil they do it as goodies and baddies which is slightly different okay good is that is then fair enough the greeks are freedom loving rugged farmers you know that they're sort of russell crowe figures the persians are are dissipated by luxury they are cruel they are oriental they are they're they're pure sort of orientalist fantasy is that do you have any truck with any of that or do you think there do you think there is a moral dimension to this story or not?
好吧，我认为如果你通过希腊人的眼睛来看待它，这是一个令人难以置信的激动人心的故事。是的。我认为这种激动人心是职业历史学家低估了的历史的一部分。嗯，这绝对是真的。趣味性。你知道的，是的。
Well, what I think is that it's an incredibly exciting story if you look at it through the eyes of the Greeks. Yeah. And I think that excitement is a kind of underestimated part of history among professional historians. Well, that's certainly true. Fun. You know, yes.
我的意思是，这就是那个让我对希腊、对古典历史、对历史本身着迷的故事。我觉得它惊险刺激，而且我觉得它惊险刺激的方式，就跟我觉得《指环王》惊险刺激，或者不列颠战役的故事惊险刺激一样，因为以少胜多的故事——你能产生共鸣的少数人抵挡住了一股庞大而逼近的军队——本身就惊险刺激，我不会去……我的意思是，当然，我认为故事更复杂，我认为波斯有很多东西实际上是令人印象深刻的，而且我认为——我不确信历史应该以好人和坏人的角度来看待。但无论如何，但我确实认为，如果你
I mean, this is the story that got me obsessed by by greece by classical history by history full stop i found it thrilling and i found it thrilling in the way that i found lord of the rings thrilling or the story of the battle of britain thrilling because the story of massively outnumbered people that you can identify with holding off a kind of you know vast force emerging and descending on you is inherently thrilling and i wouldn't want to um i mean i think of course i think the story is more complicated i think that that you know there's so much about persia that is kind of impressive and i think i mean i'm not convinced that that history should be seen in terms of goodies and baddies anyway but but but what i do think is that if
在这方面太教条主义了，如果你太过于……哦，你知道的，“我不想对此显得欧洲中心主义”或者别的什么，你就会错过世界历史上最伟大的叙事之一，错过享受它的机会。因为如果你能从那个立场抽身出来，纯粹去享受它——那种戏剧性，把自己代入到温泉关一个斯巴达人的凉鞋里，看着尘土飞扬的云团向你逼近；或者把自己代入到阿特米西昂的雅典舰队里，看到斯基亚托斯岛上闪烁的警告灯；或者然后，你知道的，这种体验让你在情感上与一个雅典人看到自己的城市燃烧时的恐惧产生共鸣，然后是萨拉米斯大捷时那种如释重负的狂喜感——我的意思是，那是一种惊险刺激的
you are too kind of purist about that if you're you're too kind of uh oh you know i i don't want to be eurocentric about this or anything you're missing out on one of the great narratives of world history of getting hit of enjoying it because if you can just step back from that and just kind of enjoy it the drama of you know put yourself in the in in the sandals of a spartan at thermopylae seeing the dust cloud approaching you or the Athenian fleet at Artemision seeing the the warning light flash on Scyathos or then you know this experience for you know emotionally identify with the horror of an Athenian seeing his city burn and then the the kind of exultant sense of relief at the victory at Salamis i mean that that is it's a kind of thrilling
惊险刺激的叙事，去感受阿基里斯的力量与荣耀，并不意味着你不对赫克托耳产生同情。是的，我完全同意。但如果你对此表现得过于假正经，你就会让自己与一个极其戏剧性的故事隔绝。我不能赞同你更多了，而且我认为你把这个故事讲得太精彩了。为了免得你……让我自己来吧：你的书《波斯之火》是一本极佳的读物，任何喜欢这个播客过去几集的人，我相信都会非常喜欢你讲述这个故事的方式——也许不如希罗多德的版本那么好，但你可以去读我的译本。所以基本上你可以
thrilling narrative and you know to to kind of feel a sense of the power and the glory of achilles doesn't mean that you don't have sympathy for hector yeah okay i completely but i think to be too priggish about it you're cutting yourself off from you know what is what is an incredibly dramatic story i couldn't agree with you more and i think you've told the story brilliantly and to save you from uh doing it i should do it myself your book persian fire is a terrific read and anybody who has enjoyed the last couple of episodes of this podcast i'm sure will really enjoy the way you you tell the story maybe not quite as good as herodotus's version but you can read you can read my translation of that you can so so basically you can you can
过度沉浸在汤姆·霍兰的世界里：你可以先读汤姆·霍兰写的希罗多德，然后再听汤姆·霍兰本人给你讲故事。你太客气了，显然你病得不轻，对吧？但是——不过我会说的是，关于希罗多德，我之所以最初读希罗多德，正是出于我童年对波斯战争故事的痴迷，而且希罗多德一直是我生命中最重要的经典作品，陪伴我走过最长的时间。但我要说的是，这个故事也陪伴了我的一生——我的意思是，它是我迷上的第一个伟大的历史故事，我一生中一次又一次地写它、重写它。其中一个兴趣所在、令人着迷的地方在于，因为我
overindulge on tom holland you can read tom holland as herodotus and then tom holland as himself telling you the story it's very it's very kind of you and and clearly you're very ill yes but what but what i would say so what i think about herodotus so it was on the back of my childhood obsession with with the story of the persian wars that i first read herodotus and herodotus has been the kind of classic that's accompanied me through my life most of all but i would say that this story also has accompanied me through my life i mean it it was the one of you know it was the first great story from history that i became obsessed by and i i've written it and rewritten it again and again over my life and one of the one of the interests of that one of the fascinations is that because i've i've been
对它着迷了这么久，我可以追踪自己思想的演变。我认为，对历史的特定领域保持痴迷，当你变老时，这就是乐趣之一。你可以，你知道的，你可以追踪到不仅你对它的看法发生了改变，而且你对生活的整个看法也发生了改变。就像我和一个每周三天的工作制一样，汤姆。正是如此。我刚才想的正是这个。詹姆斯·卡拉汉（James Callaghan）的一生同样如此。同样惊心动魄。所以，汤姆，你现在可以不用说话了。你的表现太出色了，
obsessed by it for so long i can track the evolution of my thought and i think that that's you know that being obsessed about a particular area of history. You know, that's one of the joys of it is you get older. Is that you can, you know, you can you can kind of track how how you're not just you're thinking about that has has changed, but how your whole outlook on life has changed as well. Just like me with a three day week, Tom. It is. That's exactly what I was thinking. The life of James Callaghan, likewise. Right. Equally thrilling. So, Tom, you can stop talking now. You've put in a brilliant performance
因为我们录了这两集。大家可能不会意识到这一点，但我们是一气呵成录完的。所以你基本上已经连续讲了两个半小时了。现在你可以去让你的嗓子休息一下了。其他人，非常感谢你们的收听。
because we've done those two episodes. People won't realise this, but we've done them back to back. So you've basically been talking for the past two and a half hours. So now you can go and rest your voice. Everybody else, thank you very much for listening.
希望你们喜欢，我们下期再见。再见。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前访问、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。就是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
I hope you've enjoyed it and we will see you next time. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我希望你们喜欢这期节目，我们下次再见。再见。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的剩余》。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。